brian is in Orlando hi Brian how are you
I'm doing well Dave thank you so much
for taking my call how are you
better than I deserve what's up hey I'm
trying to figure out what's best for our
family here we've got another little one
on the way so the snowball is paused but
just looking over all the numbers we're
pretty far in debt you know going
through we've met in PA school so we
have a good shovel for our student loan
issue how much do you make um about them
every month we bring in about ten
thousand okay so you're making 120 only
one of you working no both of us are
working
I guess that's we've got a few things
going HSAs pulling out for that to help
pay for the big deductible coming up
with a high deductible for the baby but
buddy A's ought to be making 100 apiece
man y'all not makin 180
huh close to yes okay that's a lot more
than $10,000 a month so you need to
really look at that if y'all got a bunch
of deductions coming out get a big tax
refund um we got about 4,000 coming back
in tax so there is some that we need to
adjust their yes not a bunch but okay
are you putting a bunch of money in
401ks
no we have stopped that and that's part
of my question is stop that yes amount
of debt and time that we have yes for
until you get your debt cleared and I'm
guessing you got what six figures are
student loans
yeah how much we so the total debt
starting out with everything consumer
included was 287 of that currently right
now only 182 is student loans and so
we've paid off quite a bit we started
about 2012-2013 so we paid off about 105
of all of our debt how much other debt
have you got other than your house we
had dock itis and got new vehicles I
have a truck how they sound yet no
they're not we have one hundred eighty
eight thousand dollars in student loan
debt and kids popping out everywhere I
mean you got dude you got him you got to
get real serious about this this is a
dadgum mess yes sir
don't you think I do absolutely all
right
yeah so what I would do is put
everything on pause until baby comes and
let's pile up as much cash as we can
pile up I'm putting a couple of these
cars on the market we're getting us a
couple of hoop piece we're going to quit
acting like we're docks and because
we're broke docks and we're going to
clean this mess up because you've got a
future for these kids you worked so hard
to become pas and you're smart people
intellectually I know that because dumb
people don't get through what you've
been through school wise so we know
you're both bright there's no question
about that
and like you said you have the potential
to have a really good shovel cut your
cuts your deductions down or whatever
you're having coming out of your check I
don't know what it is to almost nothing
other than the prop prop the proper
amount of tax is being withheld and then
when baby comes let's just let's just
roll our sleeves up and start punching
this thing in the face and make it go
away you can be done in what two three
years and start to have a life but if
you continue to drive fifty thousand
dollars where the vehicles while you're
trying to do this you're not going to do
it it's going to take you five or six
seven years and you'll lose the
emotional steam to get through it and I
just I want a better life for you than
that man you've worked so hard and
you're so smart to get to where you are
but you're gonna have to focus just like
you focused on getting through school
you're going to focus on this debt it
becomes the enemy you're fighting the
disease man you have a financial disease
and it's a pervasive at this point
ouch you can do it though call me back
and tell me when you when you if you got
any other questions or if you're winning
and you want to just cheer a little bit
I'd like to hear good things happening
for you brother thanks for the call hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you